it's
thrifty week and by now um i don't know
if any of you know this but i even have
a hashtag beautyjunkie um because i am
one and i love keeping up with the
latest beauty trends i have a beauty
company flower beauty we've had it for
10 years and today we're going to take
it to the drugstore and we're talking
beauty on a budget we received a beauty
sos from a nurse in new jersey and we
had to invite her here for one of my
favorite segments on this show called
beauty in a box
so
i would like to welcome
carmen diaz
[Applause]
i'm so glad you're here carmen thank you
joe and really i'm glad to be here so
why don't you tell everyone what your
beauty sos is well now especially that
i'm a nurse and i'm wearing a mask all
the time i was wanting to have something
that would absolutely make my eyes pop
since that's really the only thing that
people unfortunately are getting to see
of us
okay well let's get started here's what
i put together for you bring forward
your box
so
one thing i thought that would be nice
to start with an eyelash curler now i
went with the tweezer man because i
think that's my favorite drugstore brand
tweezer man gets it right so you want to
give a nice squeeze
and get them as close to the lash line
without
really pinching your skin and you just
want to rest it up there you'll you'll
feel give it a gentle squeeze and you'll
be like i've got skin i've got skin i
don't have skin
and then you give it a nice curl i've
taken the lashes from going at this
angle to this angle
then um i got for you
a
l'oreal
voluminous mascara but i got it for you
in this really rich deep plummy maroon
color oh
i took into account the color of your
pupils um and i think that this is
really beautiful next to your rich brown
and you're just gonna go in there
and
work the lashes up go from the base
especially now that you lifted it up now
what i like about this is this is a very
rich magenta color so in light it'll
catch and be really beautiful next to
your pupils how do you avoid like you
see how i got a little glop on the on my
eyelid
a q-tip
okay
because that's gonna happen that happens
to everybody that's just something that
that occurs yes carmen yes i can see a
difference already i can't your eyes are
catching the light and they're sparkling
i'm really i can tell from here
[Applause]
now
this is
this is flower beauty which is a mass
brand you can find it all these
different mass retailers i mentioned
walmart i mean we're everywhere so
you're going to go on the lower water
line with this so you're going to pull
your eye down and just go right inside
right there
and you want it to have a little bit of
brightness but a tiny bit of that flesh
tone color good
very nice carmen oh i'm so pleased um
okay now with this
um this is a wet and wild
and i'm just gonna go
dab on the lid dab on the lid and what
this does is it's gonna be wet so you're
going to be able to move your finger
around and just get a little application
on there and it'll set and dry
and it's going to catch light the
magenta is going to catch the light and
people are going to go
the white on the water line is going to
pop your eyes and make it look
more awake
the curling is going to open up your
eyes definitely need to look more awake
i'm loving it
now i love this brand revolution
um and it's fantastic so what i'm gonna
have you do here
i want you to
jack up those brows
okay okay and how you do that is there's
a great practice in beauty called like
soap brows and basically what that is is
just putting a little product on a brush
that will kind of put like this great
non-waxy but a little bit of a residue
that will keep it in place so what you
want to do
is kind of rub it in the water rub it in
the product
all the runway and beauty trends are all
about getting those fabulous brows that
we all had in the 80s they're back
i have those well stack them up carmen
because you're totally on trend when you
do that
so you know it just gives a little
emphasis
i think you look so great and i really
like the results go ahead keep working
on those brows i want you to think like
rod stewart's hair oh okay you know
thank you i love when people get the
references sometimes when you speak to
gen ziers you're like
joke and they're like
and you're like right i gotta tell you
i'm not kidding carmen you the light is
hitting your eyes it looks so beautiful
and
natural
yes
which what makes you so beautiful your
natural beauty thank you so much i so
appreciate that it's like therapy in a
box
okay so the cost of all these drugstore
items comes to 38 dollars
um so okay you're gonna go home with
everything in this beauty box and i'm
also gonna give you a 500 gift card
so
you know
if you do feel like closing
um or i've missed anything you can
shop for yourself as well thank you
thank you so much thank you this is uh
anniversary and birthday gift of wrapped
in one thank you so much what
anniversary i made 33 years at the
hospital
33 years at the hospital
carmen diaz thank you so much
[Applause]
[Music]